[Musik]
und jetzt das heute schon mit heinz wolf
uns marietta slomka
guten abend an die arbeit hatte merkel
gestern ihren bisherigen mitarbeitern
fröhlich zugerufen bevor sie selbst das
kanzleramt verließ an arbeit mangelt es
im kanzleramt und ministerien ja auch
war nicht nicht angefangen mit der
korona krise dazu kommen wir später noch
wenden uns aber erstmal anderen
krisenherden zu nämlich jenen mit denen
die neue außenministerin von tag eins an
beschäftigt ist annalena baerbock reiste
zuerst nach paris heute weiter nach
brüssel morgen nach warschau die erste
station paris war ein selbstläufer da
macht außenministerin seien richtig
freude
anderes ist sehr viel schwieriger allen
voran das verhältnis zu russland oder
china es wird interessant zu beobachten
wie berbalk die moralischen werte die
sie als grüne oppositionspolitikerin
vertrag mit der realpolitik im neuen amt
verbindet beobachtungen dazu von andreas
kienast
die erste frage die man sich in brüssel
stellt wo ist annalena baerbock
eingefahren des tallis 94 27 aus paris
an bord muss die neue bundesministerin
des auswärtigen sein die sich am morgen
in frankreich vorgestellt hat und am
mittag zwischen touristen und pendlern
erkannt werden muss berbalk auf
bahnsteig 4 das bild ist wohlüberlegt
und führt zur zweiten frage die man in
europa stellt wer ist annalena baerbock
dass deutschlands außenpolitik in
zukunft grüner feministischer und im
zweifel kritischer werden soll hat nicht
alle mitgliedstaaten begeistert der box
botschaft des tages sie will akzente
ändern nicht die welt es wichtig
deutlich zu machen dass deutschland für
eine starke europäische union eintritt
und wir in freundschaft weiter politik
machen und freundschaft heißt gerade
auch bei kritischen fragen offen und
ehrlich miteinander zu sprechen
ob berbalk wirklich offen wirklich
offener sprechen wird als zb der eu
außenbeauftragte borel haben box
kritiker nicht abgewartet china warnt
deutschland man brauche brückenbauer an
stadtmauer bauer russische medien ätzend
über anna lena breschnew selten hat eine
amtszeit mit so viel vorschuss kritik
begonnen deutschland braucht auch aus
ökonomischen gründen intakte beziehungen
das wird sache auch der außenministerin
sein die aufrecht zu erhalten und nicht
nach dem motto
vorzugehen am grünen wesen soll die welt
genesen
der aktuelle bundeskanzler bremst
berbalk freundlicher aber auch er bremst
scholz warnt seine außenministerin vor
einem vorschnellen diplomatischen
boykott der olympischen spiele in china
ist auch erstmal so dass wir diesen
gedanken geht es nicht beiseite packen
sollten der mit olympia verbunden ist
die außenministerin wird nicht hinfahren
es geht nicht darum dass die athletinnen
athleten teilweise ihr leben lang sich
darauf vorbereiten jetzt bestraft werden
dafür dass politik findet man sollte mit
china anders umgehen aber habt
kabinettsmitglieder den ich dafür
zuständig sind sollten dass unsere sich
nicht in frage es ist ein ernster
konflikt bernburg die offener und
ehrlicher sprechen wollte scholz der
ohnehin wenig sagt und china am liebsten
gar nichts was deutschland nun tun wird
wird berbalk am morgen in paris gefragt
es geht nicht nur um china sondern auch
darum wer diese neue ministerin ist
bundesregierung
europäischen freunden das klingt nicht
höffner und nicht ehrlicher als bei
früheren außenministern es klingt
diplomatisch es ist jetzt ihr job
interessant wird auch sein inwieweit die
grüne außenministerin sich überhaupt
neben dem spd kanzleramt entfalten kann
das problem hat sie aber nicht allein
christian lindner etwa sitzt am
kabinettstisch mit einem kanzler der
zugleich sein amtsvorgänger als
finanzminister ist und damit
zwangsläufig einen erheblichen
erfahrungs und wissensvorsprung in
diesem so zentralen risse hat da kann
noch so eifrig beteuert werden dass man
sich reihum auf augenhöhe bewegen es
wird reibung geben und es werden macht
fragen gestellt werden wie tag eins für
bundeskanzler scholz verlief zeichnet
christian hübscher nach der erste
arbeitstag für olaf scholz bringt
zugleich den ersten schnee in berlin
bitte keine ampel wortspiele mehr jetzt
wird regiert und wie so ein
bundeskanzler zeitplan ist straff erste
öffentliche termin 9 uhr im bundestag
von dort geht's nochmal zurück an die
alte wirkungsstätte
scholz übergibt das finanzministerium
ein christian lindner es ist eine tolle
aufgabe
ich war gerne bundesminister finanzen
und ich bin sicher du wirst das auch
gerne sein ich komme in dieses haus mit
eigenen vorstellungen und ideen aber
auch mit großer demut und respekt eine
stunde später scholz verabschiedet den
bisherigen regierungssprecher steffen
seibert und stellt dessen nachfolger vor
das mit dem foto das üben sie noch
steffen hebestreit ist auch ein früherer
journalist und war zuvor bereits
sprecher von scholz ich bin jetzt der
neue
kanzler kann ich schon versprechen dass
er demnächst tik tok tanzen kann wenn
wir das gemeinsam entscheiden der blick
deutet mir an dass wir da noch ein paar
diskussionen führen werden und es gibt
weitere staffelstab übergaben heute
bettina stark watzinger von der fdp
übernimmt das bildungsministerium die
grüne anne spiegel zieht im
familienministerium ein der fdp lama
kobusch man übernimmt das
justizministerium und die grünen steffi
lemke das umweltministerium von svenja
schulze die nun entwicklungsministerin
14 uhr ein internationaler video gipfel
mit us präsident joe biden der neue
deutsche bundeskanzler ist zugeschaltet
zeitgleich schalteten sich auch die
ministerpräsidenten zusammen es wird der
erste bund länder gipfel ohne angela
merkel scholz wird später dazustoßen sie
beschließen da etwas zu unternehmen
gegen hass und hetze auf plattformen wie
telegramm dort hat er es unter anderem
morddrohungen gegen den sächsischen
ministerpräsidenten kretzschmar gegeben
das ist unerträglich und das kann dafür
auch keine entschuldigung geben für das
was sich da abspielt und das kann schon
gar keine entschuldigung geben für
fackel aufmärsche vor privathäusern die
denn da sind sich deshalb einig dass
kommunikationsplattformen mit
öffentlichen gruppen eine angemessene
regulierung im netzwerk durchsetzungs
gesetz dürfen impfpflicht imf logistik
belarus um all das ging es heute auch
bei dieser mpk eine schonfrist bekommt
dieser bundeskanzler jedenfalls nicht
ja und auch die neue bundesinnenminister
ist von tag eins an mit wirklich
schwierigen themen konfrontiert damit
beginnen die nachrichten von heinz wolf
in den ministerien nancy faeser hatte
heute einen termin in brüssel die eu
innenminister haben erneut über den
umgang mit den flüchtlingen an der
grenze zu belarus beraten die eu länder
werfen dem belarussischen machthaber
lukaschenko vor die krise dort zu
inszenieren um sich für eu sanktionen zu
rechnen die neue deutsche
innenministerin feser äußerte sich vor
beginn der beratungen zur lage in dem
grenzgebiet für mich ist es aber auch
wichtig dass rechtliche standards
eingehalten werden an der grenze
deswegen wäre ein einsatz von frontex
dort gut und was ebenso wichtig für mich
ist ist das auch die hilfsorganisation
jederzeit zugang zu den menschen
bekommen
rund drei wochen vor beginn der
französischen eu-ratspräsidentschaft hat
sich präsident makro für ein starkes und
souveränes europa ausgesprochen als
prioritäten der französischen
präsidentschaft nannte er einen
verbesserten schutz der außengrenzen des
schengen raums eine gemeinsame
verteidigung und neue haushaltsrecht
linien demnach sollen die schuldenregeln
so verändert werden dass nach der
pandemie investitionen und
wirtschaftswachstum gefördert werden
können
us präsident biden hat demokratische
regierungen weltweit zum zusammenhalt
aufgerufen
zum auftakt eines zweitägigen video
gipfels mit vertretern aus mehr als 100
staaten sagte er die demokratie stehe
vor alarmierenden herausforderungen es
brauche vorkämpfer um den
demokratieabbau weltweit aufzuhalten die
usa wollen mehrere 100 millionen
us-dollar investieren etwa um die
pressefreiheit weltweit zu unterstützen
oder korruption zu bekämpfen nicht zu
dem gipfel eingeladen waren unter
anderem russland und china
in der korona pandemie sind nach einer
studie des un kinderhilfswerks unicef
weltweit 100 millionen kinder zusätzlich
in armut geraten das entspricht einem
anstieg von 10 prozent seit 2009 10 eine
verschlechterte medizinische versorgung
sowie die zunahme von kinderarbeit und
akuter mangelernährung erforderten ein
entschlossenes gegensteuern der
regierungen so unicef die organisation
spricht von der schlimmsten krise für
kinder in ihrer 75 jährigen geschichte
zu den aktuellen corona zahlen in
deutschland das robert koch institut
meldet 70 1611 neuinfektionen innerhalb
von 24 stunden das sind
2598 weniger als vor einer woche 465
todesfälle kamen hinzu die sieben tage
incident sinkt leicht auf 4
122,3
die stiko hat heute ihre empfehlung für
die kinder impfung unter zwölf jahren
abgegeben und wie immer in dieser
pandemie wenn die stiko eine krone
empfehlung abgibt heißt es reihum na
endlich die rechtlich entscheidende
zulassung des kinder im stopps gibt es
ja bereits darüber spreche ich gleich
auch noch mit stiko chef thomas mertens
und werden auch fragen warum die
empfehlung nicht eindeutig ist sondern
mit einschränkungen welchen räumen
sollen sich eltern darauf nun machen
doch zunächst der bericht von eva
schiller
wegen der unsicherheit vieler eltern hat
man in dieser reutlinger
kinderarztpraxis eine zweite
telefonleitung eingerichtet es klingelt
pausenlos können sie mein kind gegen
korona impfen soll ich muss ich
vielleicht bald jetzt herrscht zumindest
etwas klarheit die stiko empfiehlt die
impfung nur für vor erkrankte kinder
theo reckert fühlt sich bestätigt
gesunde kinder zu impfen findet er im
moment unnötig denn seine erfahrung ist
sie stecken corona gut weg
und insofern ist die unsicherheit
brauchen die kinder impfung wirklich
reduziert man für sie irgend ein
substanzielles risiko da würde ich sagen
das ist wahrscheinlich marginal kinder
unter zwölf impfen oder nicht um diese
frage ist eine art glaubenskampf
entbrannt kinderärzte sind genauso
gespalten wie viele eltern
man hat ja das gefühl man es nicht
machen wird das dann machen wir uns
sicher weiter nicht keiner weiß es
wirklich genau sind einfach nicht genug
studien zwischen schön von elf jahren da
und das der stiko chefs sein kind nicht
impfen ist natürlich nicht gerade
förderlich in der entscheidung der
kinder impfstoff ist schon zugelassen
die ständige impfkommission hat noch
gezögert heute empfiehlt sie die impfung
erst mal nur für kinder mit
vorerkrankungen oder mit engem kontakt
zu risikogruppen es ist damit zu rechnen
dass irgendwann ja speziell die usa und
israel die ja schon groß und umfang
kinder impfen dazu
daten haben werden also wenn dort
nebenwirkungen auftreten dann werden wir
das einiger zeit in einigen wochen
erfahren und dann kann man unter
umständen neu bewerten doch derweil
steigt die sieben tage incidents bei
kindern rasant waren im juli noch fünf
von 100.000 kindern infiziert sind es
953 in der vergangenen woche das berge
risiken finden virologen ist
im moment eine entscheidung für die
infektion und das ist einfach dieses
dilemma was wir haben wir sehen eben
dass es da eben auch schwerkranke kinder
gibt und das wird eben auch zu nehmen je
mehr kinder sich jetzt in den nächsten
wochen infizieren ins klinik vom
stuttgart kamen bislang wenig
kinderwägen corona 18 wurden aufgrund
von teams eine multi organ versagen
eingeliefert ausgelöst durch eine corona
infektion insgesamt liegt das risiko an
krebs zu erkranken bei etwa eins zu 3000
das ist wenig für infektiologen aber
dennoch ein grund zu impfen ich verstehe
jede familie die sagt sie wollen dass
ihre kinder geimpft werden dass diese
kinder nicht mehr in quarantäne müssen
dass diese kinder niemanden anstecken
müssen und auch folgeerkrankungen nicht
kriegen ich verstehe auch leute die
sagen wir sind zurückhaltend und
akzeptieren dass das dieses kind
irgendwann eine kurve infektion haben
wird ab nächster woche werden die ärzte
hier impfen jeden fall einzeln prüfen
das ermöglicht die stiko empfehlung
ausdrücklich und so bleibt die
entscheidung letztlich doch weiter den
eltern überlassen
darüber wollen wir mit dem stiko
vorsitzenden thomas merken sprechen
guten abend herr mertens und
russland je nach ihrer empfehlung in
anführungsstrichen heute sind die eltern
so schlau als wie zuvor warum nicht
eindeutiger in die eine oder andere
richtung
weil die gesamte datenlage die wir
analysiert haben einschließlich der
daten aus der jetzt laufenden
sogenannten vierten welle in deutschland
das nicht hergeben eine eindeutige
empfehlung für die impfung
und auf der anderen seite wollten wir ja
den eltern die unbedingt die impfung
wünschen aus was immer für gründen dies
nicht verwehren insofern glaube ich dass
es in der summe eine ganz vernünftige
empfehlung ist warum fehlen ihnen die
daten also die ema hat ja zugelassen ist
gab ja studien und den usa wird jetzt
schon seit ende oktober gab es da schon
die zulassung sind inzwischen über fünf
millionen kinder geimpft war eine
million wenn ich das richtig im kopf hat
die zahlen auch schon eine zweitimpfung
das sind ja unheimlich viele daten
eigentlich die sie haben haben sie da
daten über schäden über schwere
komplikationen die sie zögern lassen
also zunächst mal die immer hat
zugelassen aufgrund der unterlagen der
zulassungsstudie und wir wissen ja alle
mittlerweile hinlänglich dass diese
ungefähr 1500 kinder die da in der
zulassungsstudie geimpft worden sind
kein
ausschluss von auch nur selten
geschweige denn sehr seltenen
nebenwirkungen möglich machen das ist
eigentlich und bestreitbar so und es
durch jeden nachrichten war was die
impfungen in den vereinigten staaten
angeht so ist es richtig da sind
impfungen durchgeführt worden und das
sind auch allerdings nicht sehr viele
zwei impfungen durchgeführt worden und
wer hat aber eine million stimmt das
nicht
also weiterhin können das ist ja eine
ganze menge also das meldete jedenfalls
die amerikanischen behörden und darauf
berufen sich auch amerikanische und
deutsche biologen
also wir sprachen sehr kürzlich mit
einem vertreter des cdc da lautet die
zahlen noch etwas anders aber gutes
schreitet ja fort mit dem film funk aber
wir wollen uns nicht daran festhalten in
welchem ich will mich nicht daran
festhalten der punkt ist dass die
aussage das so und so viele kinder
geimpft worden sind eigentlich nicht
hilfreich ist wir brauchen die
auswertung von daten und studien die
sich aus dieser infektion ergeben und
die liegen in der tat nicht vor der zeit
das ist auch nicht zu erwarten weil es
in den vereinigten staaten genau wie bei
uns ein so genanntes spontan
meldeverfahren gibt das heißt da können
vermutete oder tatsächliche nebenwirkung
spontan gemeldet werden genau wie bei
uns an das paul-ehrlich-institut und wir
wissen sehr genau seit vielen jahren
dass es da eine erhebliche verzögerung
bei den meldungen gibt im augenblick
aber was er wissen es das kogit auch bei
kindern schäden hervorrufen kann und
dass moment die dieses virus regelrecht
durchseucht finden sie das richtig sind
sie für eine so genannte natürliche
immunität dass die kinder nach
möglichkeit alle dieses virus bekommen
das wird ja mehr oder weniger passieren
entweder impfung oder infektion
ja das wird so passieren aber
nichtsdestotrotz center das jetzt im
augenblick an der aktuellen situation
für uns nichts und wie sie ja richtig
gesagt haben haben wir die impfung auch
für die
menschen die die impfung wünschen für
ihre kinder und gegebenenfalls will
elfjährige sie selbst wünschen auch
ermöglicht aber es ist doch ein
erheblicher unterschied ob man sozusagen
die impfung ermöglicht oder ob man die
impfung ausdrücklich empfiehlt und für
diese ausdrückliche empfehlung die sie
gerne hätten da sie ist die datenlage im
augenblick noch zu sagen hätte ich das
natürlich gesagt haben ich würde mein
kind nicht impfen lassen haben sie eine
ausdrückliche empfehlung gegeben ohne
datenlage und prinzip haben sie gesagt
ich nicht und darauf hören jede menge
ärzte und eltern also sie neben enormen
einfluss als stiko chef obwohl sie
gleichzeitig sagen eigentlich fehlen uns
die daten und nee wir haben noch keine
im schäden vorliegen und die könnten ja
noch irgendwann kommen aber es könnten
ja auch irgendwann schäden überführt
kommen die wir moment auch also kenne
ist zunächst möchte ich doch mal sagen
dass dieses aus dem völlig aus dem
zusammenhang gerissene
aussage dieser aussage ja so nie
getroffen wurden das ist jetzt aber
einmal
kfz post genau das was ein sehr langes
interview insgesamt und in diesem
interview habe ich versucht die
entscheidungsgrundlage der stiko zu
verdeutlichen und ich habe am ende auf
die direkte frage der journalisten
gesagt die sozusagen angehängt war die
frage an eine lange an ein langes
interview habe ich gesagt ich würde
jetzt im augenblick mein kind nicht
impfen lassen und das in dem
zusammenhang mit der erklärten tatsache
dass es kein für kinder konfektionierten
impfstoff gab und der tatsache dass es
auch noch keine endgültige empfehlung
der impfung durch die stiko gab konnten
die stiko sind sie ja gewissermaßen auch
selber aber die zulassung gab es ja und
der impfstoff der wird ja jetzt auch
ausgeliefert also wird es mitte märz
geben das problem ist dass sie auch beim
boosten ja eher zögerlich war nicht auch
bei der empfehlung für die schwangeren
die ein erhöhtes risiko haben für
schwere verläufe und auch mit angie sich
fehlgeburten und ähnlichen auch sehr
spät fand am ende dann sagten dass es
irgendwie nicht gut gelaufen hätte
schneller sein können haben sie manchmal
das gefühl das ist überhaupt noch
angemessen dass sie eine solche
verantwortung haben obwohl sie
offenkundig habe personell wie sie
selber sagen als stiko eigentlich
überfordert sind
sie stellen viele fragen lassen aber
wenig antworten zu also kommen wir doch
noch mal zurück einen augenblick auf die
vereinigten staaten
dort hat der kollege uns gesagt dass es
bisher sehr wenige mehr krediten in der
altersgruppe neun bis elf jahren fünf
bis elf jahre gegeben hat und dass sie
aber selbst genau natürlich wissen dass
dieses
meldesystem ist nicht zulässt dies
abschliessend zu beurteilen das ist die
eine aussage die ich gerne noch anfügen
durch die jetzt sagen sie das mit den
ständigen verzögerungen durch die stiko
ist wenn man sich die daten anguckt der
publikationen und der entscheidung die
dort getroffen sind und in eine
reihenfolge bringt ist das so gar nicht
richtig außerdem habe ich gesagt es wäre
günstiger gewesen wenn man mit der
brüstung der älteren menschen also der
menschen mit besonderem risiko früher
angefangen haben das richtig aber wie
gesagt die generelle aussage dass wir so
viele dinge verzögert hätten ist nicht
korrekt und wir haben eigentlich immer
die aussagen dann getroffen und die
empfehlung dann geändert oder auch
angepasst wenn die entsprechende daten
vorlagen merken es danken für das
gespräch bitteschön und jetzt nochmal
heinz mit dem blick auf die finanzmärkte
da gab es heute interessante neuigkeiten
von vw es fand eine aufsichtsratssitzung
statt mit beschlüssen zum vorstandsteam
frank bethmann was ändert sich da nach
volkswagen chef herbert diess bleibt der
erste mann auf der wolfsburger
kommandobrücke aber nach zuletzt
heftigen machtkämpfen mit den
belegschaftsvertretern muss er
kompetenzen abgeben deshalb wird der
vorstand erweitert und umgebaut
wichtigste veränderung dies verliert das
für den konzern so wichtige
china-geschäft an ralf brandstetter den
jetzt 92 starken mann bei vw noch hinter
dies dies selbst soll sich künftig mehr
um die strategische ausrichtung des
konzerns kümmern also letztendlich um
die frage wie gelingt des volkswagen das
selbst erklärte ziel zu erreichen
nämlich bis 2025 marktführer bei den
elektrofahrzeugen zu werden derzeit
läuft es gerade in china mehr als
schleppend der aufsichtsrat hat zudem
heute ein neues investitionsprogramm
beschlossen ja das ist die zweite große
neuigkeit der vw konzern erhöhten
nochmals seine schlagzahl nimmt in den
kommenden fünf jahren noch mehr geld in
die hand 160 milliarden euro will der
autobauer in neue werke und modelle
stecken allein 21 milliarden davon
fließen in die niedersächsischen
standorte in wolfsburg soll eine neue
richtungsweisende fabrik der zukunft
entstehen in diesem vorzeigewerk am
stammsitz soll dann bald das auto gebaut
werden das als basis für viele weitere
modelle dienen soll frank wittmann
vielen dank
in der fußball-europa-league hat
eintracht frankfurt bei fenerbahce
istanbul am abend eins zu eins gespielt
und sich in gruppe d platz eins
gesichert damit ist frankfurt direkt ins
achtelfinale der europa league
eingezogen
zwei tage nach dem champions league aus
hat fußball-bundesligist er bleibt sich
mit domenico tedesco einen neuen trainer
verpflichtet der disco folgt auf jesse
marsch der bereits am sonntag erlaubt
worden war der ehemalige schalke-coach
soll vize meister leipzig nach dem
absturz auf platz elf in der bundesliga
wieder zum erfolg führen
ein sehr besonderer mann feiert morgen
seinen hundertsten geburtstag georg
stefan troller eine ikone als journalist
filmemacher lebensmensch und wahl
pariser seine interviewer einen etwa
waren legendär er selbst sah sie als
ausdruck seines wir sagte seelen hungers
anderen in die seele zu schauen und
dabei viel über sich selbst zu erfahren
auf 100 jahre leben schaut er nun selbst
zurück und sagt das ging erstaunlich
schnell christel haas hat ihn in paris
besucht
die hauptperson in dem film foxi spielt
heute mal die nebenrolle der kater ist
erst vor kurzem bei georg stefan troller
eingezogen für beide war es liebe auf
den ersten blick obwohl doch eigentlich
menschen das hauptaugenmerk crawlers
sind seine dokumentarfilme seine
interviews mit den großen und den
unbekannten dieser welt sind legendär
für das zdf findet er in den 70ern ein
format das fernseh generationen prägen
wird
personenbeschreibung
das symbol bietet sich an die gläserne
wand die zwischen peter handke und
seiner umwelt steht es muss ein gefühl
sein dass wir alle tief in uns tragen
schon schwere hand gemischt mit 33 ein
so erfolgreicher schriftsteller geworden
ich denke mir dass ich diese erzählte
langen wendungen die sich ausschließlich
mit menschen befasst haben gemacht habe
um mir selber die forscher geben mit
menschen vertraut zu werden und weil ich
eigentlich von natur erschweren menschen
schreiben
das sagt ein mann der sie fast alle zum
reden gebracht hat ihnen mit seiner
besonderen art zu fragen so viel
persönliches entlockt hat haben sie den
beruf mann zu sein gelernt
das einzige was ich gelernt habe
mit meinen früheren frauen in frieden zu
leben 100 jahre sind eine lange zeit mit
16 flieht georg stefan troller vor den
nazis aus seiner heimatstadt wien über
frankreich in die usa als amerikanischer
soldat kehrt er nach europa zurück seit
1949 lebt er in paris in dieser straße
im siebten stock um die ecke der
eiffelturm warum eigentlich paris ich
war ja nicht verliebt in paris obwohl
alle leute das annahmen aber
das leben
als genuss 5 in oder als genuss
möglichkeit zu entwinden weil die
französischen die pariser rische vorgabe
seine einblicke in dieses paris machen
troller in deutschland berühmt die
sendung pariser journal erweckt in den
sechzigerjahren fernweh bei den
zuschauern es gibt so eine art von paris
mythos wonach hier immer die sonne
scheint die das stadtbild bunt und
fröhlich und die menschen immer guter
dinge das war damals und heute auch mit
100 controller nicht untätig sein in
seinem arbeitszimmer er nennt ist die
hölle erst kreative unordnung er
schreibt bücher und für eine zeitung vor
kurzem hatte das bundesverdienstkreuz am
bande erhalten wenn das mein vater noch
erlebt hätte murmelt roller und sagt
dann diesen satz der so viel über ihn
aussagt ich kann nicht genau sagen also
sagt gesagt hätte
also das tier was geworden ist ich
verstehe es ja nicht aber
wir verstehen das war's im heute-journal
und gleich nach dem wetter geht es bei
maybrit illner weiter die mit ihren
gästen über corona und vor allem omikron
redet mit dabei sind neun minister karl
lauterbach und die wissenschaftlerin wie
oder trixi mann und unserer heutigen
update gibt es dann um 0.30 mit
christina von hungen sternberg es morgen
auf wiedersehen wiedersehen
[Musik]
und herzlich willkommen zum wetter das
schwer gebiete im osten deutschlands
oder auch im südosten verschwindet
allmählich von westen her kommt aber das
nächste tief und bringt morgen
tagesverlauf für schnee vor allem
oberhalb von 400 metern
sonst ist es meist regen und sie sehen
auch diesen roten pfeil das ist warme
luft die uns dann am sonntag erreicht
oder auch regen mitbringt dieser regen
gefriert allerdings dann im osten
deutschlands und sorgt für glatte
straßen ist erst einmal zukunftsmusik
wir schauen in die kommende nacht und da
haben wir es mit schauern zu tun regen
und schnee teils überfrierende nässe und
dann gibt's glatte straßen das auch im
osten hier fällt noch etwas schnee das
wird allmählich weniger an den alpen
klart es auf und über den schnee flächen
teilweise temperaturen mit -10 und
vielleicht auch etwas darunter sonst sei
sich auch im osten deutschlands mit
minus 3 grad im südwesten minus 1 bis
minus zwei grad im nordwesten frostfrei
bei +3 grad morgen tagesverlauf also
neuer schnee von südwesten allerdings
fällt oberhalb von 400 metern dieser
schnee sonst wird es regen seien im
hochschwarzwald ist es außerdem windig
mit sturmböen dort mit schneeverwehungen
zu rechnen ansonsten teils sonnige
abschnitte in den östlichen landesteilen
temperaturen dazu minus 1 grad am
alpenrand die höchstwerte hier also
dauerfrost 4 grad im nordwesten
ja und am samstag im süden regen und
schnee lässt allmählich nach sonst etwas
sonnenschein minus 1 bis plus fünf grad
und von westen her erreicht uns am
sonntag dann regen und der gefriert dann
vor allem nach osten hin 0 bis 10 grad
und noch ein bisschen milder am montag
bei drei bis elf grad ein schöner abend